[Music]
hey guys so guess what I'm about to do
actually you don't have to guess because
if you read the title then you'll
problem we know what I'm up to put
anything I wanted to try my hand at
baking today can you believe that I'm a
new person just kidding I really wanted
to have like some sort of hobby but
nothing too crazy I used to like baking
when I was a little girl I used to make
cookies for my mom and my brothers and
stuff and I just wanted to kind of try
my hand at it again
especially now that Casey you know he's
a cook of the house but there's no one
in the house that's a baker so I'm like
hey you know I'll try to take that role
sort of anyway I looked up this recipe
online to make a pumpkin cheesecake
because you know it's fall time and it's
my favorite ingredient of all of ever I
love pumpkin everything so I decided you
know what
I gotta try my hand at pumpkin
cheesecake it's like my favorite pumpkin
infused thing to eat so I really want
her to try it but just a fair warning I
don't know what the heck I'm doing I
just pulled up this recipe and follow
the instructions and cross my fingers
and hope that it turns out okay all I
have these folks is helping me film this
because it'll just be easier what's up
everybody
so I got the recipe here and first thing
pre-shoot together
[Music]
you don't know how to work I work it all
the time for pizza
all right so 350 all right so it says I
need graham crackers meaningful you
think its credit gonna small it's the
medium over the three that we have it's
a medium for us you know what how does
me baking now make you feel when now
you're trying to be like gluten-free and
stuff
oh right so I am trying to be more
gluten aware I'm not like Xing out all
gluten foods just because it's so hard
and I'm not devastatingly allergic to
gluten or anything like that but I do
feel a huge difference between eating
non gluten and eating gluten
yeah so I don't know if you're gonna
start baking I'm gonna have to do some
sacrificial desserts yes there's cheap
days to working out there's a cheap days
to dieting and there's cheat days to
gluten-free diets as well that's the
thing it's not like I have like I think
that gluten disease is a celiac disease
I don't know how to pronounce it just it
looks like it's celiac Celie Act there's
an actual disease where people literally
cannot eat gluten or else their
reactions are devastating enough for me
it's just my skin gets little extra
itchy boohoo so I'll take the risk for
your baking baby oh man now you're
making my bacon has to meet some very
high expectations I'm gonna melt this
that butter this isn't butter five
tablespoons of butter that's a lot of
butter yeah 20 seconds I think that's
fine I don't like the way butter ever
let's find out okay and then
microwaving for them never mind it's a
30-ton I think 20 seconds was not long
enough like 45 seconds what anything
permanent go for it
45 my hold on a second are not following
I'm actually learning with you right now
but I'm not looking at the computer
screen I'm just looking at you so what
have we tens of a [ __ ] nothing we've
just been trying to melt the butter five
tablespoons of butter yeah this is one
and a half cups one and a half cups
graham crackers get the five tablespoons
of butter oh yeah
[Music]
one tablespoon of sugar where's the
sugar over there you don't know your way
around the kitchen although in the back
[Music]
man it's all good
[Music]
put oil partway up the outside part of
an 8-inch springform pan I have a 9-inch
springform pans or press the crumbs onto
the bottom and about two-thirds of the
way up you should take my rings off
you're not married anymore you're not
married anymore
all right so kind of hard getting it up
the sides maybe I should have put a
little bit more butter how do people get
the crusts all nice and pretty
all right I think this is as good as
it's gonna get without me really getting
to obsessive over it looks pretty good
to me
so hopefully those knees bake the crust
for five minutes
then set aside until you're ready to
fill it hey Google timer for five
minutes
sorry curl okay
combine three packages of cream cheese
the star of the show okay but look you
should be proud of me
I got 1/3 less fat woo from you thank
you and for you to archers supposed to
be helped oh yeah one cup of sugar makes
you feel really unhealthy where you're
making pizza well you know what's going
into it you're like one teaspoon of
vanilla ever tried drinking vanilla
extract I never knew how to make french
toast who knows a little and she would
always put in some vanilla smell it you
can smell the alcohol true I never
linked events that that smell would lock
all I just always thought it smelled so
good do you need to be ID for vanilla
extract yes it's a lot the look I read
it the other day cuz I was looking at my
spices yeah 35% yeah
mix with an electric mixer until smooth
you bring yourself why would they do
that to me like cover the whole thing no
pay no game high five you know it's like
my baking learning experience here I'm
learning okay I'll kiss it real quick oh
thank you are you looking for your lips
what you left it the saliva is the
healing part all right I won't wipe it
off yeah you never wash that hand anyway
I bought this hand mixer for this recipe
and it got me really excited I'm like oh
my gosh we have a hand mixer now I can
bake more thing I had one of these and I
was a little but when I was try to bake
so it's kind of like nostalgic for me
right now
well what's good first don't make a mess
all right
[Music]
give me a bagel I know I like smelling
ingredients I know you keep sticking
your nose in each ingredient this whole
recipes just gonna have your boogers in
it funny sounds like the inside of your
mouth Oh
shoutouts to Wong foo we did a video
with Wong foo a long long time ago and
then they were like hey you guys want a
really cool high-tech trash can I'm like
hey yeah we freaking love this trash can
it's not sponsored video by the way but
we just really like this trash
yeah it's on voice command you say open
can it'll open is open right open can
it's such a funny thing in there that I
get excited for trash anyway thanks a
lot cinnamon nutmeg and allspice
I got you I know where those things are
okay this is a racer what are we doing
here it's not a race it's just let me do
it okay go ahead do it let me do it dad
down there right there I got 1/2 a
teaspoon of cinnamon 1/4 of allspice
then 1/4 of nutmeg oh I think it smells
so good when you mix all that up
together can I smell it it's coming
through the camera yeah he's kind of
sour that was cool
did you get that there's like a gun yeah
you're so cute
[Music]
you're always cute adorable stop it
there's scrunches like the cheesecake
we're making why are you being so funny
there's people watching anyway we're
important so for filling in
[Music]
are you having fun I am this is fun
so my guilty pleasure is to watch cake
decorating videos and they spin the cake
and then they're using this thing and
then they're like doing this seem like
they're smoothing it out even though
this isn't a cake inside one of those
like spinning things still kind of like
giving me a little taste of that and I
can't wait so I bake 60 minutes all
right so the timer just went off I'm
really nervous
I hope this turned out okay Casey had to
go out and pick up Isaac so I don't have
them here to help me with this right now
but let's beat whoo that looks like a
decent cheesecake and Louis ghibli
supposed to be that jiggly I don't know
here we go I'm really nervous again I
mean scares me now
all right so the recipe says to let it
cool until it's a room temperature and
then we put it in the refrigerator and
then we wait for it to chill but it
looks pretty good I'm kind of proud of
myself so far yeah well anyway I'll just
wait until tomorrow I'll let it chill
overnight and I will see you guys
tomorrow for the tasting I'm gonna have
Casey and Isaac try it and I'm so
excited I really hope it comes out good
fingers crossed we are so well that was
really fast oh you know you were all
concerned about not getting a perfect
crust good I'm so proud of myself
really Oh what if I cut it crooked I'm
so nervous
and there's where I'm gonna cut it here
we go oh man
hey when that happens
look we could cheat it we can be stuff
it in there like this like it was always
there there we go good boy look at that
taste test okay I want to taste the
crisp I'm gonna do it from the back a
little bit of everything
whoa maybe too much
oh my god you have to it you have to you
have to taste it
don't exaggerate like for real what like
for real for real nice moment isn't that
good you bought this you should be
switched it out we're being lied to
no no honestly I think this is better
than New York cheesecake oh yeah baby
can we have five I'm gonna be baking
everyday I wish you guys would taste it
you know we just make our own I'll leave
the link of the recipe that I used down
below and then you guys can make your
own and the semi photos no we can just
be happy enjoy it and revel in our
pumpkin cheese
I've never been so happy all right guys
I really hope you enjoyed my baking
pumpkin cheesecake video I can't stop
reading it let me know in comment below
what else you would like to see me
attempt to bake because I think I just
found my new hobby
[Music]